the people on the left seem to think
that when joe biden keeps his promises
it makes him more popular what if when
joe biden keeps his promises it makes
him less popular because his promises
suck how about that
new polling shows according to nbc news
that more people oppose the vaccine
mandates then favor the vaccine mandates
i said this all along i said that the
early polling that showed that vaccine
mandates were popular that was because a
lot of the people who were in favor of
vaccine mandates were already vaccinated
but then it dawned on them wait a second
if there are vaccine mandates i might
have to get a booster maybe i don't want
to get a booster
if there are vaccine mandates what if
that means there's no stuff on the
shelves of the store where i want to buy
things what if it means that i call 911
and no cop shows up
so now 47 favor of the vaccine mandates
50 opposed but here's the more important
stat only 34 of americans strongly favor
a vaccine mandate as opposed to 41
percent who strongly oppose the vaccine
mandate remember when i said that the
only people who are passionate about
these issues are the people who oppose
correct
okay so joe biden seems to make the
common mistake of looking at poll
numbers and believing that because
people say they like a thing it's a high
priority for them and that is not the
same thing at all
speaking of things where people say that
they are interested in it but they're
really not interested in it this brings
us to joe biden and the climate
conference which we're supposed to all
pretend is super important even though
china and russia are not there and china
is the world's leading emitter
cop 26 the united nations the most
eisley of international politics a
wretched hive of scum and villainy
according to the wall street journal
president biden told world leaders at
the cop26 summit that the coming decade
would be decisive in the fight against
climate change wow
wow he said it would be decisive
uh incredible i mean i'm like i'm
stunned by the amount of bravery that
took stunning bravery with brave
stunningness
hours later indian prime minister
narendra modi gave a slower than
expected deadline for slashing his
country's emissions saying india would
take as long as 2070 to reduce its net
greenhouse gases to zero
oh you mean because they wish to develop
and carbon is cheap you mean you mean
that
oh
oops so joe biden's like this is the
okay that matters we have to save the
world and then meanwhile in india which
is emitting at crazy rates like
what if we just wait until 2070.
what you can do about it joe whatcha
gonna do about it
the gap according to the wall street
journal highlights a fundamental divide
between developing and developed nations
days after leaders of the group of 20
major economies made little progress
hammering out specific climate goals
many had hoped would ease discussions in
scotland
speaking to leaders and government
officials from most of the world's
nations mr biden warned that none of us
can escape the worst that is yet to come
the doomsday cult that is the climate
change movement is really crazy
we'll never escape really we've escaped
literally for all of human history we
have adapted the human species to
changing climate we are now better
equipped to adapt to changing climate
than at any time in human history which
is why climate deaths year on year
continue to drop even though the climate
is indeed changing
but we have to pretend that the only way
to prevent the bad effects of climate
change is to prevent climate change
itself by completely crippling the
economy
and so we're just going to alarm you
into do it but my favorite thing is when
joe biden is trying to alarm you into
doing things by using extraordinarily
purple language and then when it comes
down to what are you actually willing to
do joe he's like well we do need cheaper
gas here is joe biden at cop26
explaining this is an existential threat
to humanity it is not an existential
threat to humanity literally no one who
has worth their salt in this area
believes that climate change is going to
wipe human beings off planet earth no
one believes that that's crazy talk
here's joe biden engaging in some crazy
talk that again because we live in a
crazy era is taken seriously
right now
we're still falling short
there's no more time to hang back or sit
in the fence or argue amongst ourselves
this is the challenge of our collective
lifetimes
the existential threat threat to human
existence as we know it
and every day we delay
the cost of inaction increases
so let this be the moment that we answer
history's call here in glasgow let this
be the moment when we answer yeah yeah
good luck with that
but and then he says it's an inflection
point in world history all this
bloviating honestly the carbon emissions
coming out of this dude's mouth are
going to change the climate by a couple
of degrees celsius over the course of
the next century
within the growing catastrophe
i believe there's an incredible
opportunity
not just for the united states but for
all of us
we're standing at an inflection point in
world history
we have the ability to invest in
ourselves
and build an equitable clean energy
future and in the process create
millions of good playing jobs and
opportunities around the world
yeah okay if anybody believes by the way
the green energy sector is going to make
up for the carbon sector right now you
are out of your mind no one believes
this if that were the case by the way
then the investment community would have
already dumped money into this area to
the extent that we would already be
transforming and in some areas we are
right i mean we already have teslas
right
like electric cars aren't going to be a
thing but here's the thing cars are
actually not the chief source of
emissions when it comes to climate
actual power plants are the chief source
of emission when it comes to climate and
developing nations need those
and then joe biden went on to apologize
for donald trump pulling out of the
paris agreement as though the paris
agreement meant to anything i do like
john kerry the easter island head behind
joe biden
the the old white face of the
anti-climate change movement is really
uh really always astonishingly inspiring
i guess i shouldn't apologize but i do
apologize for the fact the united states
uh
the last administration pulled out of
the paris accords and put us sort of
behind
people
yeah i put us back in the useless
agreement that didn't do anything
i mean nobody kept to it but it was i
hate trump so you know
okay so all this is so exciting and so
necessary and so deeply moving joe i
mean joe biden is so
there for it he is so on the mark he is
like if called upon he will spring to
his feet he will answer the call this is
the inflection point we have to prevent
the catastrophe of a world boiling
itself to death joe biden fell asleep
like actually fell asleep in the middle
of one of these climate change
conferences
you can see him there he is eyes start
to close
and joe biden is gone he is now sleeping
in the middle of this conference there
he is he is clearly out he's clearly out
cold like my baby in the back seat of
the car in a long drive joe biden is
gone he is just
slow in fact joe biden had to be woken
up by an aide to clap at the end of the
speech i am not kidding you that is a
thing that actually happened
our daughtering elderly
the the face of a decaying west is joe
biden
a career politician who's never done a
productive thing in his entire life
who is now the president of the united
states pledging to destroy
the fundamental institutions of the west
ranging from family to free market in
order to achieve a utopian vision that
will never be achieved but will maximize
the power of old people like joe biden
like that that is that is
he's a pretty good metaphor he is just
like as a human he's just a good
metaphor for what's happening
right now
by the way the same joe biden
who is suggesting that we have reached
the end that it's all over we've reached
the end uh he's seeking more oil
production according to the new york
times
oops
days earlier according to the new york
times he was urging the world's largest
oil producers to pump more
the incongruity was on center stage both
at the global climate summit currently
taking place in scotland and in rome
this past weekend during a gathering of
leaders from the 20 largest economies
according to the new york times the
president's comments highlighted the
political and economic realities facing
politicians as they grapple with climate
change on the surface it seems like an
irony said biden but the truth of the
matter is you've all known everybody
knows the idea we're going to be able to
move to renewable energy overnight was
just not rational
um
you could
let the pumping slow and raise the
prices and let your constituents suffer
you could do that if you are joe biden
now you could do that but then you'd
bear the political brunt he's not
willing to do that which is amazing for
a guy who says we have to have the
courage to move into a new tomorrow
it's super important move into a new
tomorrow
meanwhile by the way the tech community
is mobilizing on behalf of the
propaganda as poor as per usual
arrangement according to the washington
post twitter now says that they're going
to attempt to combat climate
disinformation by steering its massive
user base to reliable information with
more context a strategy the company
calls pre-bunking
or
you could go with just propagandizing
the rollout coincides with the un cop 26
climate summit in glasgow scotland by
the way that is not going to make people
suspicious of the institutional powers
that be at all when you coordinate what
information people can see we won't be
we'll probably believe you probably we
won't be suspicious at all that maybe
this is part of a larger plan to reshape
the institutions of the planet
twitter users will be directed to online
hubs containing credible authoritative
information according to a company blog
post these guides will appear in users
explore tabs their twitter search
portals and relevant trends lists
according to a twitter spokesperson the
platform wants to get ahead of any
coordinated falsehoods that could
surface during the summit which aims to
chart an aggressive course to cut
greenhouse gas emissions and slow
earth's warming
so the company spokesperson says they
need reliable authoritative hubs of
information from global experts
yeah i'm i'm sure that'll go well
whenever you have our institutional
bettors telling you what you can and
cannot see and how you ought to think
about crucial issues that affect your
life
that that definitely fosters trust
the belief by all these people that the
more they control your life the more you
trust them is totally crazy but it is
something that they continue to double
down on over and over and over again on
everything from education to climate
change
did you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist tier that
is just science
[Music]